good morning everybody Welcome to
Transportation being 9:33 we'll get
started uh before we do actually get
into the non main Amendment hearing can
pledge United States of America and to
the rep stand One Nation God
all okay I'm going to open up the public
hearing on a non gerain Amendment for
House Bill
1158 and it was close to being Germain
uh deals with the same section of law
just a different paragraph So to be on
the safe side I was told I should have a
hearing so we're going to have a hearing
so uh this came up I'll let
representative Lynn explain how this all
happened um and introduce him good
morning
sir
good morning members of the committee um
my name is Bob Lynn I'm a representative
from Windam Rockingham District 17 and I
want to thank you uh for uh
accommodating uh this uh request for for
a non- gerain amend amendment to 1150
House Bill 1158 let me explain to you
the way that this came up I'm a member
of uh uh jel car uh the administr rules
you know sort of oversight committee and
during a uh the last proceeding of Jael
car an issue came up um about the
process of uh the department of safety
dealing with um people who have a
federal license to operate um a a boat
or a ship I'm I'm I'm not really into
this so I'm gonna I'm G to have somebody
who actually knows the details of what
they're talking about explain in more
detail but um there there was a a
question about whether or not the
department of safety had the authority
to require somebody who has a federal
license to operate a boat to take a uh a
practical skills for a lack of a better
term practical skills test before
getting before being allowed to operate
um uh in state waters and the department
of safety apparently is doing that and
and it seems to me that and I'll let
them explain but it seems to me that
that that it makes a lot of sense for
them to be doing that the problem was
that the federal that that our our state
statute seems to say if you've got a
federal license you you get a state
license you don't need this and the
state can't do anything anything else um
and so the you know the state basically
was saying well this this if if that's
what the if that's what the state
statute says that's a problem because we
think there really is a good reason for
us to be uh requiring this sort of
practical uh test and I think most many
of the people on Jael car agreed that
that made that there was good reason for
them to do that but nonetheless it
seemed to conflict with the statute and
so um chairman McGuire of jail car
suggested that since I had a bill that
was at least somewhat related to this
that maybe it would make sense to talk
about a a a non-g gerain amendment I
talked with uh attorney hilz from
Department of Safety um who was kind
enough to draft something pretty quickly
uh and I spoke with the with the chair
here about that and so as a result you
have uh my Amendment 2024
87h um
and with that I'm happy to take any
questions but I think in terms of the
details of this you're probably going to
learn more from attorney hilts or the
captain from uh Marine Patrol than you
will from me but I'm I'm happy to try to
answer any questions if I
can thank you sir and and for the
committee I have signed up David hiltz
from safety who's the attorney of the
drafted the language and Tim dunlevy
also so the questions might be better
directed towards him any questions for
for representative Lyn seeing none thank
you very much sir all right so and so
you know can I just ask you on the on
the on the other do you want to conclude
that first or do you want should I talk
also about the the sort of Germain issue
this hearing is Germain nerain only okay
and we'll be doing a work session with
your other Amendment later on in the day
terrific thank you so much for
you uh next up I will introduce or ask
see David Hill
from Department of Safety in support of
the bill uh the amendment sorry it's
that good morning um my name is attorney
Dave hiltz I represent the New Hampshire
Department of Safety with me today I
have Captain uh Tim dunlevy from Marine
Patrol uh we're here to testify in
support of this non- gerain bill and we
do deeply appreciate this committee's
willingness to entertain this on short
uh such short notice um just to drill
down a little bit on what representative
Lynn said um it kind of boils down to we
had a statute it said two things and um
as we are going through uh the rules
committee on the watercraft safety rules
which is the safe C 400 rules it it
seemed like there was an opportunity to
clarify those two points in the statute
so the two points being that the um
department is authorized to administer
an exam for people seeking author
ization to operate a a commercial uh
boat and the second is what the scope is
of any exemption from those examination
requirements if the person is a holder
of a federal license so those are the
two things that currently exist in the
statute but it seems like it'd be a good
idea to clarify those two things so as
the representative previously testified
when the department saw the current
authority to administer an examination
we took that to authorize both both a
written exam and practical exam um and
the captain could speak in Greater
detail if the um committee were
interested but essentially we think that
those two parts of the exam are critical
you know one you did demonstrate the
book knowledge you know that you that
that you need to have to operate a
commercial vessel but the other is that
you can actually demonstrate that you
have the skills and the capability to
Pilot a commercial boat which the um the
amendment would defined as something as
34 ft and greater in length to trigger
that um practical examination
requirement so um it's sort of like the
difference between if you were in the
Navy and you piloted all manner of boats
and then when you come out you know you
know could you drive the Mount
Washington maybe but it's really not the
same thing as a destroyer or some other
you know military craft and so before
you know we as the regulating agency
would let somebody uh take that step and
pile it a few hundred people on a uh
boat like the Mount Washington you need
to demonstrate your ability to to Pilot
that ship um so you know this amendment
does two things one it
clarifies that the existing examination
Authority that we have in fact
authorizes both types a written and a
practical um and it has the criteria for
administering the Practical in the uh in
the amendment and then also um we
clarified the scope of the exemption so
that if you did have a federal license
you know in this subject area that you
could be exempt from the uh written
requirement the written examination but
not the Practical because we still feel
that it's very important that you know
you demonstrate that you can translate
any skills that you have so um that's
what the amendment does um the
department would be deeply appreciative
if the committee uh uh passed uh pass
the amendment and I happy to take your
questions or if we'd like to have the
captain
come I'll do Captain D Levy separate uh
any questions from the committee
representative Jones Thank you Mr chair
uh let me ask you first is there is
there a speaker from the Lakes
management advisory committee coming up
do you have a pin card for them if so
I'll save my
question no I've only got two more
people signed up to speak that's from
Department of Safety and an organization
called Watermark moing construction or
Marine construction okay can I ask my
question now sure okay uh the uh Lakes
man management advisory committee was uh
opposed to this bill because of uh the
equity among all the sizes of vessels
does is this addressed in the amendment
is that are they satisfied with
this thank you for your question um I
don't have any knowledge of that not
been in touch with anybody from the
Lakes Region
um entity that you mentioned um we
haven't received any criticism you know
either as the department or in the
context of being in front of jail car
that there's an issue with you know the
length of the boats that are captured by
this um the captain very well may be
able to speak to this um so um with your
permission I could with his um thank you
hold on you'll have another chance at it
and and there's another suggestion
question too but um we we'll get that in
a second anybody else any other
questions from the committee ripson
sakes thank you Mr chairman thank you uh
attorney hiltz for taking my question um
the thing that I'm struggling with is um
in prior testimony for the the original
bill that this is being tacked on to
there was
this concern over how do you define a
commercial vehicle
and I I see all of
this
fine um will this
cover the point of
the
small as the original bill called you
know
for uh very small vessels that they
don't get more than $5,000 worth of
whatever
and if you if you know if you do these
two meld I guess is is the easiest way
and ask the question because I want to
make sure we're F not adding this and
creating a further problem for the
original
Bill thank you very much for your
question I I have the feeling that the
answer to this is going to be a little
bit of a team effort um just because of
my participation in this has me thinking
that I have a little bit of information
on that the captain probably does and
and I actually think the representative
does too but maybe he left um but but
the way that I understand it um is that
the the original intent of the bill uh
is essentially an exemption you know
it's an exemption from being required to
obtain certification to operate a a boat
you know
commercially um and I really don't see
any reason why there should be any uh
conflict between accomplishing that via
that language but yet on this on this
amendment here this non- gerain
amendment we're clarifying what the
nature of the examination is for those
who must take it you know what I mean so
it's like if the if you decide to pass
an exemption um that has to do with you
know a very small length of of the of a
boat you know much smaller than the 34
feet that this amendment would require
and the activities are restricted to
certain things you know the prepackaged
foods and you know the other asset ects
of that exemption then that exemption
will be there and those people because
of the language of the exemption won't
have to take an exam so it really
doesn't matter that this amendment
defines the nature of the exam if you're
required to take it um that's sort of
the way I that I see it I hope that I
question okay thank you we I'm sure
we'll hear some follow-up information
from the good
Captain OB up Landon thank you Mr chair
thank you m um this is obviously for
vessels registered in New Hampshire
saltwater and fresh water so my question
is to your knowledge to does the state
of Maine and Massachusetts have similar
legislation regarding boats of this size
and tests as were outlined here in this
amendment thank you for your question
I'm not able to answer that question
maybe that's something that the captain
could weigh
on thank you
any other questions seeing none thanks
very much thank you
um going to shake things up a little bit
here um Chair recogniz say Paul a good
one uh Watermark Marine construction is
suggestions for the record my name is
Paul Goodwin I own and operate Watermark
Marine construction um little background
I uh I've been doing this a long time
couple more years than Captain dun Ley
but not by much um and uh I've had a
commercial boat license in New Hampshire
for 40 years give or take a little bit
um we operate barges and boats and we
build docks break Waters boat houses and
things like that um relatively involved
in the lake I was on the wetlands
Council for quite a while I was on the
Lakes management advisory committee for
quite a while
um and I would probably guess that I
have more time on Lon basaki than
anybody working in the industry right
now um like I said I've had a commercial
boat license for all that time and I
have never been asked to take a
practical test so I don't believe that
requirement at least in my lifetime has
ever come to fruition because I don't
know of any none of my guys have ever
taken a practical test we all everybody
that Ops ores a vessel obviously has a
commercial bull
license um we we have about 30 people
and we operate a bunch of workboats a
workboat is very similar to driving a
just a pleasure boat so there's not a
big skill set difference there um but
our barges and things are quite
different and unique so we're pushing
barges with uh smaller vessels called
pushbots or or tugboats and uh it's
quite a skill set to to operate those
and so we answer to OSHA and our
insurance company more than we answered
anybody else quite honestly that's
pretty true in the construction industry
overall but in-house we train our people
to drive the boats we don't rely on
anybody else and I don't know that
there's anybody at Marine Patrol that's
familiar with that type of operation of
a
boat um as I said we've all passed the
commercial vat test the written test
which I think could have a better study
guide but it's a difficult test and
there's a note here about a local
website Who Says how difficult it is um
but uh it it's not easy you do have to
understand what's going on
this this seems to change things quite a
bit by adding the Practical exam um and
I have a few questions on that but I I
don't understand where the 34 feet came
from um seems like an interesting number
but um like I said the smaller boats are
just like driving a pleasure boat it's
not really a big deal but um please
understand the US Coast Guard does not
require practical exam um same thing you
may have OSHA and you may have very
strict insurance regulations if you're a
tug tugboat captain or a tanker captain
or something like that but the whole the
whole postard licensing procedures based
on your experience and you have to prove
that experience you get affidavits from
people you get recommendations there's
so many days that see you have to have
um and uh it's it's not an easy license
to get um so you're wonder what if if
the Coast Guard doesn't require it how
how would the trainers be trained what
would the standards be for that testing
I mean we need to know all that as a
business ahead of time before we send
somebody over for a practical exam uh
I'm a pivate pilot and I'm I'm also a
tractor trailer driver Class A do
license and you you get your license
based on what you're doing so for
example I'm a single engine land plane
pilot but you might be a single engine C
plane pilot you might be a rotorcraft or
helicopter pilot you might be a twin
engine pilot you might be a commercial
pilot dot tractor trailer is my license
it's Class A Class B depends on the
weights of the vehicle so now we get
into I don't know if there will be
different testing standards for
different vessels especially as it comes
to the practice iCal side of the exam um
that that would be an interesting
question um and also we have a lot of
vessels I I don't know how many boats we
have I've lost track but maybe we have
30 boats um maybe 40 um only a couple of
them are over 34 feet because as I said
we're operating tug boats and push boats
that tend to be smaller pushing a barge
um but would we have to take multiple
tests and get multiple practical
practical exams from multiple vessels um
that would that might be completely
different in how they're operated if
you're operating a commercial commercial
sailboat is much different than bringing
a tanker into Portsmouth Harbor or
something like that so um I think that
that needs some
work
um the the communication I've had with
Captain Dunley seems to lead me to
believe that this is mostly being driven
by Passenger vessels so the suggestion I
have is perhaps adding that caveat that
you need to be show Proficiency in
driving a passenger vessel uh as far as
the Practical exam goes um noting again
that the Coast Guard don't believe Maine
or or Massachusetts require I don't know
if any state that requires practic those
S um but I don't pretend to know all the
states by any means um you know our
barges operate between five and 10 knots
so you've got plenty of time to react to
something going on it's not we're not
going fast we tend tend to be heavy and
slow um so I think that perhaps
specifying that passenger vessels are
where we're concerned about public
safety and and a practical exam uh
secondly because the Coast Guard is
based on experience I'd suggest adding
some sort of a grandfathering clause I
mean here I am 40 years in doing this
probably nobody has my experience and
I'm GNA have to take a test to prove I
know how to drive something that I do
every day you know when the ice is not
frozen so I just think there may be a
way to add a petition or something like
that or some sort of experience where
you could get a waiver on that based on
how long you've been doing it and I
suggest the the window of a commercial
boat license is five years so if you've
had your license for five years maybe
you could be grandfathered to not have
to take a practical test um and then I
will add one other thing because I do
not have a US Coast Guard license I
don't need one but the way this reads to
me uh in the second section where it
says the the license from the federal
government you'd be exempt from the
written exam it doesn't say exam so that
tells me that this might give the Marine
Patrol requirement to go down to
Portsmith and have a foreign ship
captain or tanker or whatever delivering
to Portsmith come taken to Hampshire
practical exam and I know that I don't
believe that's the intent but that's
certainly what it says to me as a Layman
but um the captains of a big ship or the
captains under the Coast Guard are
pretty strictly regulated in experience
and medical training fire training
safety training and I just don't think
there's any reason for the Marine get
involved at that level nor do I think
they want to but uh Captain Dunley can
speak to that um and I've summarized
everything in this letter that I handed
out so thank you thank you very much sir
questions from the
committee represent Coker thank you Mr
chair and uh thank you for your time so
my understanding is is that literally if
it's a US Flagship and your Coast Guard
licensed Captain it's kind of almost a
self-promoting thing where you just work
your way up by vehicle size and
literally it can go up to like a cruise
ship if it was flagged under the US and
they would not need a practical exam is
that correct is that your understanding
of it too it is and um I I didn't
mention in here about a learner's permit
or something like when you're learning
to fly you get a student pilot if you're
a truck driver you get a learner's
permit you have to build that experience
so the Coast Guard requires basically
days at Sea yeah there are separate
licenses for say the Mississippi River
which is a completely different skill
set pushing you know 100 barges at a
time so yes it's based on that but those
Industries are also very regulated
in-house and they are Insurance also is
the biggest thank you any other
questions representative Hill thank you
Mr chairman uh and thank you Mr Goodman
for taking the time um you are primarily
Inland Waters is that um is is there a
need do you think to set up different
skill sets for Inland versus um Coastal
there's probably not a requirement to do
it coastally because the requirements of
the Coast Guard are I believe it's 26
feet um you don't actually need to be a
captain but the things I'm talking about
are the ships that that come into
Portsmouth Harbor those are directly
regulated by the Coast Guard and they
actively do that so I don't think
there's a requirement that this has to
have that at all okay I think the
exemption would be if you have that
coast guard license you don't need the
new
hampire thank you representative C I was
just curious since you mentioned
Portsmith does this mean that the
various Tugboat operators down there
would have to go get a
license they'd have to take a practical
exam in Hampshire the way I read this
but they already have to have a coast
guard license thank
you any other
questions represent sellers thank you Mr
chair so you mentioned days at Sea is
that would that be similar to number of
hours as far as the be certified so I
believe the Coast Guard not 100% on this
but I believe a 4H hour day is a day at
se we get a little bit stuck with a
regulation that's very weird called the
line so in New England New Hampshire and
Maine especially you have to go outside
a line line that's drawn from Portland
New Hampshire Portland Maine to the cape
so I've been out in some pretty scary
stuff inside that line but the Coast
Guard doesn't count that as c y so your
Inland license is different than your
Coastal
license any other questions seeing none
thank you very much thank you very much
and I thought this was going to be easy
chair recognizes Captain dun Levy from
welcome good morning Mr chairman
honorable members of the committee Tim
Dunley I'm representing the Marine
Patrol this morning I come in support of
this bill and um I will I will
anticipate some of the questions uh that
may be coming from what I heard a moment
ago from the perspective of the length
that this vessel that this uh amendment
is is directing itself toward uh 34 feet
the state took a look at the types of
vessels that we see that give us concern
particularly when it comes to the transp
ation of the public um the Mount
Washington is the obvious example but
when you look at a lot of what our kids
summer camps especially on our larger
Lakes they're getting uh 40 and 50 foot
uh Transportation boats for their kids
camps where a counselor who's 18 years
of age can be transporting 50 kids to
we's Beach to go up to the arcades let's
say um so we took it we took a look at
what are the types of vessels that we
have the greatest concern with that
they're transporting the greatest number
of people and 34 ft number one could
handle a large much larger capacity and
number two often times those vessels
were at least twin engine which
operation we are not looking to impact
the uh uh the the bill that this is
attached to whatsoever that bill is
dealing with vessels that are less than
16 18 ft in length so we're we're we're
not even close to being having any
impact on on that original
pill uh as far as the Coast Guard is
concerned the Coast Guard as you heard
uh from Mr Goodwin has a very
um involved process to be able to
achieve a captain's license whatever
tonnage your certification may be you do
need to demonstrate SE time we do not
have that mechanism in place on on New
Hampshire land Waters we do not get
involved with shipping on our Sea Coast
because we recognize the Coast Guard and
the federal jurisdiction and the things
that a person needs to meet before
they're even uh in in the Wheelhouse of
a vessel of that size we
do um uh license smaller uh uh fishing
charges and that sort of thing uh but
again we're not talking uh commercial
shipping or anything like that nor do we
want to get involved with that uh Mr
Goodwin statement was very accurate uh
when it comes to that so um that's what
we're looking to do um certainly any
process or any practical exam that that
this bill would allow us to do is going
to have rulem of its own uh we're just
trying to clarify that that person who
comes to us with that federal
license who maybe if you want to use the
airline analogy has operated a
commercial airliner all their life
retires and all of a sudden wants to
start taking people up for SE plane
rides we just want to make sure that
that person can drive the SE plane yeah
they can drive the 747 but there are
differences and that's the difference we
want to make sure when somebody gets to
behind the wheel of the Mount Washington
or the Thomas not the Thomas Leon but
the uh Mount sopy or the Big Bear Camp
Sandy Island whatever it might be that
while they're transporting those people
they can do so safely and are proficient
and I'm happy to answer any other
questions that I may have
missed thank you sir representative
Crawford thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking my question would this
require the department of safety to hire
extra people to test all these
um voters uh no uh right now we're doing
it um uh we do about 600 inspections
about 600 license exams every year when
we look at the the number of people who
are actually
operating vessels at this size
particularly uh uh uh passenger vessels
we might be looking at a half dozen a
lift representative Coker thank you Mr
chair thank you Captain um so the
question the the Practical exam is kind
of where I have the most questions about
because when you go over so I'm I'm an
airline pilot and every when I over a
certain size I have to get individually
typ rated on each airplane that I fly
commercially so like when I look at this
I go a vehicle that's that's maybe 30 to
50 feet you know probably they're going
to be similar enough that you know you
you probably be able to handle if if
you're you can handle one you can
probably handle the others but about
getting over that like the Mount
Washington and the bigger vessels that's
where I see maybe more individualized
practical test so the the big issue I
have is I know it would have to go
through the rule making but like the do
you guys have like a format for a
practical exam or thoughts or like what
what are you actually like what are you
looking for on that practical
exam we're looking for first of all that
the operator has a demonstrated
knowledge of the vessel itself the fire
extinguishing systems things that an
emergency situation would require them
to know uh and then we want to see
anybody can op operate a boat on the
open Waters of Lake wiip basaki where
where someone's true skill is is is
demonstrated is when they are en Tien
quarters docking Maneuvers um Close
Quarter maneuvering is where we can
really tell whether they have a handle
on that vessel now open water absolutely
you need to know the characteristics of
of the vessel how it handles chop and
all those things but we're looking at uh
seeing a person uh properly deploying an
anchor we're not looking for them to
deploy the anchor on the Mount
Washington but know how um can they
bring the boat into the dock in Alton
and wolfboro when you've got an East
Wind um those are things that we're
looking for approaching a buoy making
sure that they they have knowledge of
New Hampshire's uh buoy system it's
academic knowledge but do they have that
knowledge the ability to read that
Compass they come to us with certain
licenses and credentials but they've
never applied it on New Hampshire's
unique navigation system so those are
the things we're looking for one more
follow real quick yeah follow up thank
you chairman um so how would like from
just a practical St stand point I would
assume like the crew of the Mount
Washington would have a a very good
working knowledge of the Mount
Washington how would the Marine Patrol
be able to have a higher level of
knowledge to be able to evaluate
somebody on on a vehicle on a
specialized vehicle like that I mean is
there or would you guys like contract
with somebody who's Captain the Mount
Washington to do the Practical test I
mean that's those are the details I'm
and and and we we've been doing it
that's why we're here uh it was jail car
identified that yeah um we
we we communicate with the Mount
Washington we jump on the boat when a
new person who is ready for their
practical exam to be taken is ready um
there's a senior captain on board and we
go along for the ride we have our
checklist uh and and observe them
bringing the boat along to the dock so
this is already somewhat of a process in
place it's a process place all right
thank you thank you
Mr representative Hill thank you Mr
chairman thank thank you for taking my
question if this was specific to
passenger carrying vessels would that
cause you
heartburn
um you you'd have to look at the
definition of a of a commercial vessel
at that point um and and whether you
create exemptions certainly uh I would
yield to your wisdom um there are people
in this room like Mr Goodwin who who
have a wealth of experience uh what what
other companies do
uh bringing someone in to operate a
large barge uh are they qualified I I
can't speak to that but what I can speak
to and what he said was certainly yes
they are regulated by osher and their
insurance companies if they carry
Insurance um and the exposure to the
public certainly is not that of of a a
passenger carrying vessel thank
you I just have one question we have two
people here with a tremendous amount of
experience Lake on Lake wab
basaki um you're telling me or telling
us that this is a process you actually
already do we just need a codified and
statute as identified and then we have
somebody else saying that if this passes
it's going to negatively and adversely
affect them I just don't know uh where
where this is going can you help me with
that
one
um Mr Goodwin uh one runs probably the
most reputable Marine construction
company uh around there are others like
him that do different things but with
with equal reputation that being said um
what as a whole in his industry people
operating large barges are they
qualified uh that would be my question
um he is correct in that they have uh
unique push push boats where they're
pushing large barges the barge is
empowered so this isn't even going to be
subject to that
um I think Al made sound like we're on
different pages I I think we're we agree
in a lot of sense as to where we need to
go no not fair enough thank you I didn't
mean to put you on the spot
representative Gorski thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question you mentioned that you've been
doing this on Lake wiip for for for
a while how many of these exams do you
do in a typical year of these practical
exams uh we do it Beyond wiip uh
again it's been uh vessel specific um it
varies on on what kind of turnover those
those folks are seeing uh within their
ranks of their
employees
um we may do a dozen a year and that
includes Camp counselors on on on on
kids camps the camps even recognize
they're going to take the veteran
counselor that's returning year after
year to operate those big boats so uh we
don't see a huge turnover uh necessarily
doesn't representative
sellers thank you Mr
chair would it be better that we maybe
tighten this up to say any vessel that's
transporting transporting passengers
would make more sense for an exam
because you're looking for safety at
that point that's what I'm wondering
I I would yield to your wisdom as a
committee um I I don't feel that I'd be
in the position without uh speaking to
my superiors about their position uh on
on sticking with just passenger
vessels I'll go in the order I saw them
represent PL pandon thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question U
kind of along the lines of the questions
of our chairman I just look for more
clarification in your earlier statements
you stated that the uh Marine uh uh
Excursion vessels deep sea and whale
watch and so on you do certify them my
question is is the certification process
in any way similar to the legislation
that we're looking at here or how are
they
certified because those are passenger
vessels they are and indeed uh if if I
said something I I misspoke we do not
touch commercial operations on our Sea
Coast like a whale watch or a commercial
fishing vessel those fall under the
strict regulations of the Coast Guard
and like quick followup follow up uh so
this legislation would in would affect
them as well going if it
passed um we have no intention for it to
uh if the language being offered does
that um it's it's not anything we do
because we recognize the federal
jurisdiction uh is more strict uh more
experienced um uh their process is sign
significantly more
involved due to not only the the nature
of the environment but the nature of the
vessels that they're overseeing thank
you thank you Mr
chair representative Sykes thank you Mr
chairman thank you Captain for taking my
question is there any practical way for
the Marine Patrol to differentiate
between a vessel that is generally used
for commercial purposes but not carry
passengers but then might on a one-off
situation suddenly turned into a vessel
passengers I suppose that could happen
sure um uh anybody could I guess take a
construction barge and turn it into you
know uh a fireworks barge or take people
out um obviously there would be an
investment on their part uh safety
equipment wise and that's sort of thing
and these vessels aren't necessarily
built for for that type of Excursion but
I suppose people can get creative and
it that's fine um representative Hill
did you still have a
question you passed representative C
thank you Mr chairman thank you for
taking the question uh do you have an
idea about how much proportion uh are
passenger vessels that you do testing
I would say
probably 20% of the overall commercial
vessels in our state 15 to 20% are
probably Marine construction
related
um the bigger question is of of those
that are not Marine construction related
that are classified as commercial how
many of those are over 34 feet and we're
probably talking
about
high all right seeing no other questions
thank
you oh representative Fox thank you Mr
chair I I have an additional question
for Mr Goodwin would that be appropriate
at some
point thank you if he wants to take it
but did would you like to take one more
dunlevy if we were to change the context
of the amendment to uh to be more
appropriate to just passenger vessels
would that affect your
opinion yeah I think that's the intent
here is to look at the public safety
aspect which is transportation of people
yes thank
you all right seeing no other questions
and nobody else signed up to speak I'm
going to close the public hearing on
number 08
870 okay so this is going to be an
unusual day um hold on to some of your
thoughts on this uh I've got the work
session on the four bills that we have
left four house bills at 10:30 I've
going to do some scrambling to find a
few more amendments that I have not seen
yet so I may be a couple minutes late um
and then uh hopefully we can uh go
through the work session if we have any
ideas that need changing with OS we'll
try to get it done today if it can't get
done today I'm leaving us a way out for
us I've already been told we have at
least five Senate bills coming so this
won't be our last day after all so so
bear with me while I try to get the rest
of our amendments together and I'll see
possible
okay good morning everybody uh sorry for
the delay I'm going to open up our uh
full committee work
session we did hold on to four bills
that we were assigned this year we
trying to make them work trying to make
them
better um I'm going to start I'm not
going to go in order I'm going to start
with House Bill
1457 which is establishing penalties for
driving over covered wooden bridges and
vehicles that exceed posted limits for
vehicular damage to covered wooden
bridges the reason I held on to that um
the clerk informed me that that should
have been a second committee bill or two
committee Bill and it should have gone
to criminal justice after we decided
policy um so what he asked me to do was
get in touch with the chair of Criminal
Justice and give him an opportunity to
put in any amendments that he thought
they would have done if it was in their
committee um he did have a couple of
ideas uh but I just did confirm with uh
ol that none were actually
submitted so that's where we're at that
right now and you know what let me get a
copy of my bill uh and we'll continue
second
okay um I guess we'll go on the
Assumption we don't have any amendments
from criminal justice but I will tell
you one of the ones with the one I do
remember that he thought was a potential
and I'll ask and see if you think it
needs to go anywhere he was concerned
with the increase in the fines maybe we
should amend this to specify that the
fines collected
from uh violation of the wooden covered
bridges would pay for the maintenance of
the wooden covered bridges so that it
wouldn't turn into a revenue
stream however I did look at the current
statute on bridge
maintenance and basically they just
borrowed what's already in existence in
other words yeah you there is no special
fund if the if the money is collected
for a violation it is there it's not
Specialized or particular for any any
purpose any thoughts from anybody
assuming we have none from the committee
I mean from Criminal Justice what how
would you like to move forward with 1457
we've we've already I believe we're
unanimous in support of the policy
change so I'm going to leave it up to
the discretion of the committee if we
would like to look at it anymore or just
stick with our policy I'm fine with it
it represent plon U yeah just a question
to you Mr chair at we had had to heard
testimony
that some of these bridges are
maintained by the community whereas
others a state did we ever identify
where these fines would go whether to
the community or to the state or I know
you were just discussing it but I'm not
clear yeah um hold on there is a part of
this bill uh
specifies uh where the fines are in inur
my favorite word hold on one
second yeah line 17 All Fins under the
section shall endure to the municipality
or other agency that is responsible for
the bridge thank you sorry Mr that's in
the that's in the bill that we passed
representative
Jones thank you um to answer your
question Mr chair uh doesn't line 19 and
20 say
that uh they cover the
cost responsibility for full cost of
repair set a bridge doesn't that cover
what the question you asked
uh it does but it was also a concern of
the chair of Criminal Justice um you
know say somebody had a $100,000 policy
and they destroyed a million dollar
Bridge um the way this is written they
got to come up with a million bucks so
that a potential cap for damages was
also a thought of his Y and again these
are the things they were looking at I
mean when that's why I went we should
have gone there because when you start
raising the fines there's always other
things that are outside our wheelhouse
if you
will right sir representa C okay as as I
said here on line 17 Roman four that
says that the fines are going to the
agency that deals with the bridge and
then Roman five which starts on line 19
deals with u uncovering the damages that
occurred and it's I guess it's possible
that somebody could uh Drive the wrong
kind of vehicle cross the bridge and not
damage it but would still be considered
for the
fine true I'm just mentioning one of the
concerns the other committee had was
that do we would we look at a cap for
damages as opposed to putting a
multi-million
dollar penalty or replacement cost on
somebody that might have just had a bad
example
I'm just throwing these out this is a
work session it's a little different
than the way we usually format things
I'm throwing the stuff that I learned in
my conversations out there and you throw
it all back in me and at the end of the
day we'll decide what to do represent
SES so did I understand you I want to
make sure I phrase my question um did I
understand that this is now going to go
to criminal
justice there is no time so we P the
deadline for second committee bills is
passed that's why we were asked to hold
on to it and work with them to come up
with any amend we've not and we've not
heard from them and we have not so there
is another solution to this too um and I
do not do this lightly nor am I
recommending it but because we are where
we are and we didn't get any potential
amendments we let it go the way it is
and it is going to another body and
there is another opportunity for
anything to get fixed it's not that we
didn't try to do our due diligence we
did uh but we don't have anything before
us I I'm there's also the floor
Amendment route they could come up with
a floor Amendment if they wanted to
change some of this they could do that
too yeah y so my my sense of this whole
kurur fluffle about these things is
that this committee has made a very
positive statement about the
policy and we should follow through with
that and make sure that we continue to
support the policy if there are concerns
about the implementation of penalties
Etc it more appropriately belongs with
either criminal justice or if the Senate
gets the bill then they can have their
criminal justice committee take up the
bill but I think I I see no reason why
we can't pass it as it is as we already
have they had their chance too bad so
sad well I have to
agree rumo thank you may ask a question
uh based on others experience in the
room if if you were going to add a cap
or down the road an amendment were going
be made to add a cap how how do you
reach the determination of the
appropriate cap when you have you
implemented that sort of language and
other bills in the past before my time
I'm just it seems for us to do it today
seems like it would be arbitrary you
know potentially and what number we're
picking once again great question I
don't have the answer to that okay
interesting because I do that that is a
concern here clearly I mean it was a
legitimate Point yeah it is that's why I
bring it up yeah uh represent I think
isn't there a cap if you're for
uninsured vehicle uninsured motorists in
New Hampshire you're you're limited to
the total liability if you know I think
we might want to look into that and try
to see if the language would I'm sure
that people smarter than me could find
language that would show how to do it um
but again I I do agree with
representative syes at this point um
well let me take that back um I just
left the clerk's office one two three
four five six seven eight we're up to
eight Senate bills and they've just
gotten started so if you think there's
something we could still do on this it
is your choice we'll do stop Pooles on
it so I think the choice is now we'll
never get anything done for the
executive session this afternoon other
than leaving it alone and moving it
forward that would be one option two
would be to not take it up an executive
session and come up with more amendments
on our own so I think that's where we're
at for choice I vot Punk okay
and now this is why we don't see a lot
of work sessions and
Transportation uh representative blondon
how are you thank you Mr chair um as far
as I'm concerned I think this is still
good legislation I'm fine with the fines
my concern as I had mentioned in the
prior meeting is due notice um you know
a sign prior to the bridge whether it's
we had heard testimony that some of
these bridges are right off the road so
just either further down down that same
road something stating basically
historic bridge ahead oversiz load
subject to fines up to $2,000 and 100%
cost of repairs so it's due notice
there's no
excuse most of these bridges are all
signed now with the height requirements
of people are still driving over
them you give them due notice and I
think that would hold up in a court of
law any way shape or form that's my
position on and you know this is why we
go through this exercise you just
reminded me of the third point the
chairman of Criminal Justice brought up
was the same thing adequate signage with
enough time to turn around prior to
going across the bridge however we did
hear at the public hearing that there's
a lot of bridges that don't have that
opportunity that aren't and a lot of
them are already doing that so again up
to
us to follow
M again I mean even I understand your
point but on the on the road to that
bridge
Fair notice prior to that so one let him
know there's a historic Bridge coming up
it doesn't have to be directly on the
drive to the bridge I think that would
be due notice and would comply with with
in
court my position thank and I do agree
with you the only thing not mentioned is
who's paying for the signs
um again I was I pride myself in being
an organized person and I thought I had
everything nailed today and I was
waiting for three amendments from
criminal justice so that we could
discuss them and and decide up and down
I don't have them so we're punting uh
again the question of this committee is
if we're going to move it on today in
executive session as is or if we want to
hold on to it and work on it some more
representative sers thank you Mr chair
so I think we should just mooving on the
way it is but also I I believe all these
bridges are
insured and if they're insured they're
even if they're not able to collect the
the amount due from The Violator at that
point because you know their insurance
doesn't cover it the bridge is still
going to be
fixed good point I do remember that as
well representative
Hill I think we
can um easily send it on today with the
knowledge that all these great ideas
that the criminal justice committee has
still have opportunities to be heard in
the public and and debated um and so I
would have no
problem um executing it this
afternoon represent
Jones thank you I think I agree with
representative Hill but uh I just want
to ask wasn't the criminal justice Bill
wasn't that more about allowing cameras
and weren't they get jumping into our
purview no it was a different bill it
was a different Bill and both bills were
supposed to go to them eventually they
get the one specifically for cameras we
got this one for policy first and then
it was supposed to go to criminal
justice and it was it was it was the
office's mistake that it didn't go to
the second committee so that's why we
were asked to see if we could make the
changes here the deadlines have passed
um and
so we did try I understand now thank you
and again there as we all know there's
more opportunity for the things that
have come up to be to be addressed again
it's not the way we usually do things
but that's where we stand so let's do
this um just to raise a hands shall we
move forward with this and execute this
is I guess that takes care of that so
give me a few minutes to get regrouped
here um we will we are done with 1457
for
now
if you want to get your amendments ready
we'll do what we have deemed the
lemonade boat Bill
next there should be three amendments on
it uh two Germaine one for myself and
representative Lynn and then obviously
heard
all right we'll get started on this um
uh if you want to take a look at
Amendment 0882 H that's the one I
submitted that tries to address this
this the problems or tries to solve the
problems that the the reason the first
bill was submitt
admitted um it does create an exception
and I did go over this with Captain dun
Levy um I'm trying let me hold it up
against the original
Bill the concerns they had uh were
basically F first of all they were find
with an exception understanding that you
know 16 18 year olds selling prepackaged
foods and soda okay they they conceited
they're not really concerned about it
like you heard at the previous non
gerain Amendment uh passengers uh is a
concern and then also he got a good
point what if somebody that's 16 years
old wants to put a barbecue grill on
their roow booat and start selling it
with an LP you know hot food
so this language was was developed from
that so it leaves the 16 to 18 years of
vessel um on any public Waters of the
state without a ballot certificate to
act as operator of a commercial vessel
if all the follow following conditions
are met 16 ft or
less vessel will be operated only for
the selling of prepackaged foods and the
vessel shall not be operated for the
safety support of other boers swimmers
other persons in or on the water or for
incidental transportation of passengers
toying vessels refueling or
servicing in my conversations with the
captain and he did review it with the
commission they're fine with this this
creates the exception they're not going
to need to be certified they're not
going to be the expected every year um
and he said biom meain works for
us the only thing representative Lynn's
Amendment does differently which is
0903 has changed that 16 years of age to
18 from 14 to 18 so if you're okay with
what the exception
does according to the Marine Patrol then
the only question we should well the
only question I think we have as a
committee is at what age do we think
this should begin so I'll leave it to
you to ponder for a moment do we want 14
or 16 16 is current law I believe um so
we'll start with
that yep represent I I support the 14 my
my son started operating a boat when he
was like 10 and is what and at at 11 the
kid was probably more skilled at
operating about than I was so or I am
now so okay represent rbo I would add
only I feel like there are actually not
a lot of opportunities for kids in that
age range 14 to 16 to to be
entrepreneurial to be working to be
productive and so we feel like the
safety aspect is handled it's a I think
it's a limited but good opportunity for
kids representative C are there any
issues with the child labor laws or
anything relevant to that for a
14-year-old
you know I doubt it I know you can bag
you can bag at Market Basket age 14 so
there are there are and you can work at
Dunkin' Donuts I believe in some limited
capacity there are there are
opportunities okay and those and those
are federal laws that we don't have to
worry
about Fox does anyone recall the age of
the young man who brought this forward
turned 16 this summer thank you but I
think he started doing it at
14 preps have sixes so um I think we
already
give permission to 14y olds to
operate
snowmobiles and I I would be in support
of the 14 because it would be more
consistent with if 14y olds can safely
operate with it admittedly they have a
license and take an education course of
those th000 pound vehicles or whatever
they are on the snowmobile trails why
can't a young person of 14 operate on
Lake as well I think the consistency
would be helpful sure you're supposed to
be under the control of the parent
that's the only difference that's the
only difference admitted yeah thanks for
that
correction I do see representative Lyn
who'd like to chime in too anybody else
from the committee
first represent sellers thank you Mr
chair I do see on one other thing here
that
little concerning is on B on line nine
it says selling a
prepackaged food I mean do I have to put
lemonade in a in a in a bottle and have
it screw topped on and stamped or or can
cup well it says prepackaged food and or
non-alcoholic
beverages
I'll Circle that right now let's ask
representative Lynn what he thinks
because actually I believe he brought
too represent plumon thank you Mr
chair I'm just a bit concerned at the 14
I kind of lean more towards your
Amendment for the 16 I understand the
comments
made my concern is our Lakes are
becoming busier and busier and they're
becoming more analogous to our
roadways my other concern is at that age
uh there's no identification so let's
say Marine Patrol stops them or whatever
uh there's no form of of of licensure if
you will and my third concern is this
legislation doesn't specifically outline
freshwat um so theoretically
we could have the lemonade Boats off of
Portsmouth Harbor as well so those are
just some of my concerns tell me if I'm
wrong but some
chair there there is a definition in law
sorry ahead there is a definition in law
under RSA
27120 uh that does specify that um
public Waters of the state means Inland
Waters that entirely over 10 acres
entirely owned by the state so there is
miles yeah a lake that's over 10 acres
yeah freshwater lake that's it freshw
yeah not no but the there is a def
definition of public Waters of the State
under 27120 specifies Inland fresh
freshwater lakes or bodies of
water
yeah represent vnn your thoughts yeah
you know I just wanted to say um I
didn't not I didn't know this and and
maybe the committee didn't know this and
so I when I when I spoke to uh Mr Hils
from the Department of Safety about this
he tells me
that it doesn't directly apply to this
but for
non-commercial boats under with a
engines of under uh I think it's 25
horsepower it might have been 45 but 25
or 4 there's no age limit other words he
said if you're if if you're not if if
you want to operate a boat at five years
old that's not commercial there's no
you're allowed to do that so I think
that um I agree I mean obviously this
does apply this talks about an exception
for the commercial but um I think to me
14 years old does make you know does
make does make sense for I mean the the
analogy to the snowmobile whatever um I
so I I guess I think that that does make
sense the only thing I would say is that
I asked um Mr Hills what the department
of safety's position on this was and he
said in terms of 1614 he said their
position was neutral they didn't endorse
it they didn't oppose it that to the
exent that's helpful to the committee
thank you for that and you know speaking
of 14 years old the trends we're taking
right now they'll be voting soon so so I
guess they should be able to drive a
boat you know the other thing I want to
say and I I just want to take a moment
to really thank your committee you know
I know that you've got a lot of very
important bills on on your agenda and
this is not this is not a Monumental
matter I and I very much appreciate the
effort that the committee has put into
working on this I it really means a lot
to me I thank you our pleasure um
anybody else from the committee um
represent
sellers thank you Mr chair I just want
to say that when I was growing up as a
young kid I would literally take my
lawnmower out and go to different yards
and more Lawns I mean I think I was
probably 10 112 I mean this just
promotes uh entrepreneurship and and the
other thing on I'm going back to this uh
line B again on on line nine B I'm
saying we're actually limiting this to
food I mean why why can't a kid sell
fishing gear or boating gear or anything
else for that
matter you had to bring that up today
know well I I concur I mean I was 10
years old I had five accounts so I get
that so I'm fine with the 14 as well um
anybody
else representative SE I I'm fine with
it
uh I'm I'm fine with it specifying
prepack packag food and that would
assume that the beverages would be
prepackaged also so you soft drink
bottles
or um Gatorade or whatever somebody
sell representative rbo I just I I would
argue you could read this as it's okay
to have lemonade in cups it's a food as
we were hitting at before is that
problematic to others on the committee
okay and that was the intent of that
language um so I guess at this
point we could we could start making
exceptions for a lot of different
products do we want to move forward with
what we've got at this point which is
what came to us yes things can always be
added or changed in the future or
expanded or do we want to hold on to
this create a subcommittee
representative sellers that is going to
look into maybe other types of business
businesses that will be
yes raise a hands are we moving on the
Way It Is Well what age oh at 14 at
14 fair enough we'll put this one aside
and we'll deal with it this
afternoon well oh that's true that that
takes care of the Germaine amendments
now we just heard it our non gerain
is
right
H I'll open that one up for thoughts
that we heard this morning of which I
simple I think it's an interim study
quite
frankly um I think you're I
think I think we're lucky um I don't
know if I was recognized was I
recognized representative Hill thank you
um I think uh we are lucky that we heard
um from a member of the public to bring
this to our attention um otherwise we
would have been perfectly happy and blly
gone along and pass something that we
may have regretted later on so it would
seem to me
um that there is a distinction between
passenger and non-passenger commercial
type things um I don't
think as written this is um something
that I would support I would I would
easily
support this if it was um designated
strictly for passenger commercial um
which seems to be what the Marine Patrol
was getting to and intended to do I'm
still a little concerned how they are
been doing these exams without any
authorization from anything um but
that's a whole another problem um but I
would uh I would think we either need to
amend this so that it includes just
passenger Andor
um any other suggestion that the chair
may
have anybody else represent
C I'm sort of just because this was all
new and sprung on us I'm sort of of the
opinion this might be something that
ought to be brought next year as a new
bill okay let me um throw the same
options out that I did on the other Bill
I know it was just given to us uh I
truly believe it was going to be simpler
I'm glad we did get the opposing views
because I think there are questions that
need to be answered so our question is
is because it's not our last day here do
we want to move forward with our
Amendment to the original Bill and not
take this up or do we want to hold on to
this bill and work on the non gerain
Amendment based on the knowledge that we
learned this morning so I guess that's
the decision that we've
got
um representative h i compare with
representative Hill that um we just
tipped the you know gotten the tip the
iceberg of what the concerns may be I I
think I I have concerns that this may
lead to some unintended consequences as
is and even if we tried to amend it it
may end up being a you know window
tinting bill that we cause more problems
in the LA he hey hey
hey all
up did they say touche thank you for
yeah anybody else all right then I'll
look at a raise of hands I guess raise
your hand if you think uh we should not
entertain this and uh move on with the
bill the original bill as amended that
we've
got and not take up the non gerain or
okay so that's any right uh it's not
that it doesn't have any Merit I think
there's a lot of Merit but um we've got
deadlines too to get our bills done our
house bills and we're running out of
time quite frankly as well I I have a
question to the chair
what um this came to us because of um
action go ongoing with jel car what what
happens if we don't take this up um
regarding that
action well I don't know I can only
presume they're going to continue doing
it the way they've been doing it even
though they couldn't do it with no
authorization in other wordss um I don't
see any represent of SES
I just I I think the chairman earlier
had outlined some possibilities for
further action on amendments that
weren't necessarily ready for prime time
about how this committee could continue
to entertain a way to work on this there
are but I I believe we shouldn't bring
It Forward on this particular bill
because it is non gerain and also
because there's a lot of questions now
but it it's not closing the door
completely is my point of view and why
we would not take it up uh on this
particular Bill the non-gain
piece well let me take a look at the
Senate bill by title that we're getting
and maybe there's an appropriate place
second
we have till the 4th of April to report
out of committee anything we want to see
go to the floor not on a second right
well that's the last dat of report on
all house
bills
well I don't see anything in our Senate
bills yet
that that are germine but it doesn't
stop us from putting it anywhere we see
fit plus we're probably going to have
more perhaps I should have picture
framed it a little bit differently but
the question I guess still stands do we
want to pursue working on the non-
gerain amendment on this bill or would
we like to keep the the topic in mind to
work on it on a Bild that may be coming
down our way soon and we got the straw
pole that everybody said we would like
to just move on with 1158 the way it is
there okay well well that's still I
think we still need to ask gel car
whether there there is a deadline that
they have that would maybe push us to
look at it in the next month rather than
wait until the second half from the
Senate bills um I don't know let me ask
representative Lynn as a member of Jael
car what happens if we don't take this
up immediately and send it waiting for
another day you know what I I I I think
as a practical matter really nothing
happened I mean the the this issue came
up because as as I think you've heard
there was a question about whether the
whether the department of safety had
this had the authority uh to administer
these kind of practical tests um if you
know I don't I don't know this but I
assume that if if if not if the law
doesn't change Jael car uh I mean uh the
department of safety would continue with
its current practice which may be
unlawful but you know presumably if
somebody if somebody thinks it's
unlawful they'll challenge it that in
other words I'm not saying that this
doesn't need to be fixed but I do think
it may you know in light of of issues
that apparently have been raised I do
think it makes sense you know for this
committee not to act precipitously but
rather to wait and you know
look at it more carefully and and you
know like it's not gonna it's not going
to interfere with with anything that JW
car is doing um it just will leave this
this issue kind of up in the air but
that's that that's all
right in other words an analogy I like
spin so um I don't think we need to do
it again I think we're in agreement we
have this amendment keep it in your
files
and keep it in your thoughts if we see
the opportunity we can take it up uh if
not there are always other opportunities
okay so we'll leave that one
alone uh or move on with the Germaine
Amendment at 14 but we but we do still
have to amend all uh I'm just going
through this to get through what we're
prepared to do in our executive session
um the two amendments we had that were
jine excuse me um they don't they don't
need to be reconciled they are identical
except for the the age so we so we can
AR
ARR erase the Walsh Amendment and just
take the Lin Amendment correct okay no
merging necessary it's just one of the
other I didn't know if there needed to
be us any merging done of those Noe just
trying to get everything organized for
exec session so we can make it about a
20 minute
Adventure now that I Jinx
that um last one Speaking of
please
I'm actually going to recess this for 15
minutes this work session I've got to go
get a couple an questions answered
across the street so in the meantime um
you're right we're down to 1273
Amendment um
0918 and two for H Bill 1637 if you want
to continue to familiarize yourself with
11:45
okay going to reopen the uh full
committee work
session and we might as well take this
one up
original
the original title relative to the
protection of personal information in
driver's
licenses
um I have to say this is probably one of
the heaviest lifts I've seen in
transportation in a
while um I take it seriously only in the
fact or for the fact that I mean I'm old
school and I'm very weary of my license
being scanned everywhere I go for every
service but apparently not the only one
because if you remember in 2018 we not
only passed the CAC out out of this this
this house but it actually made it to
the ballot and the overwhelming majority
of people in this state are still
concerned about it as well
um
unfortunately since representative alry
put the bill in I have met every
lobbyist that's registered to do work in
this building
looking for a car route for their
particular
industry uh a lot of those car routes
are currently in 264 irsa
2614 and in an effort to eliminate all
of the concerns at this point I tried to
get an amendment drafted well I got one
drafted uh that would just kind of
concentrate on retail sales for an
example uh right now I don't know if you
know this but anytime you want to go buy
a sixpack or a pack of cigarettes they
refuse to do business with you unless
they take your license scan it and
capture your
information why and nobody knows where
that information goes I think it's
infuriating and again they Pro they deny
you Service uh if if you don't comply
with the retaining of your personal
information I just left OLS uh for a
couple questions on the amendment that
I've given you which
is 09 18h and even this one is going to
require a little bit more work
um uh to to get where I was trying to
get to in terms of just the the resid
the retail end of
things um I guess at this point we have
till what' you say March 21st on this
I'm going to ask the committee um where
you are on the theory on this and once
again we we got options we've got a
little bit of time we have interim
studies we have put it someplace else if
we can get it done I guess the first
question I got for you is do you agree
with the theory of trying to tackle this
issue or do you think we're the water is
already gone over the dam it's too late
and people are going to do whatever they
want with our information in perpetuity
what say you representative
sellers thank you Mr chair
I've had several people come to me with
this irritation of the the license being
scanned and not knowing what data is
being collected or if it's being
collected of all um I've had
conversations with DMV and and it's come
to my understanding that when you scan
that barcode on the back of your license
every bit of information on the front is
is uh available to the retailer all of
it your eyes your hair color your weight
your your height so when they only need
the date of birth to verify that you're
an certain age it's it's it's getting to
be worse and it's getting worse as the
days go on I would like to see something
past you know to at least stop the
retailers from doing this it's it's just
it's uncal for you know that's our
personal information and talking to the
MV even though they might be a rule in
place that you know they're not supposed
to do X Y and Z it's like now the
burdens on them to go find out and and
find from the retailers saying well show
us that you're not storing the data you
know and then who's going to prosecute
it because you know it it just TS to be
really really muddy at that point so we
need to do something at least maybe for
the retailers
anyway thank you and then that that's
why I get passionate about this is as
well um so the committee knows too uh in
in your looking at this uh we I believe
Senate Bill 255 that was retained last
year is on its way to the governor's
desk which also deals with privacy
unfortunately the title of that bill is
our expectation of privacy so I it's
continuing the watering down is
continuing over what I believe the
people of the state are looking for us
to do
um but but again the best I can see out
of 255 is that well if they collect your
information you can request that they
remove it and I I I don't see that as
practical I separate a lot of these
industries um you've got banking you've
got insurance uh my goodness even
Comcast was jumping up and down because
they couldn't scan people's licenses
anymore uh again I've met just about
every lobbyist in this building with an
upper Carbell I don't have a problem and
there's nothing in either the original
bill or in this amendment that says you
can't voluntarily do it if you need to
buy a new car and you and they need your
license to do it you got a choice and
with 255 you can also specifically say I
want to make sure that information is
gone but on the the the everyday retail
it could be 10 times a week could be 15
times a week I mean that's just where I
see it imp practical for 255 to even
work uh so thank you for that I agree
anybody else any
thoughts representative Gorski thank you
Mr chairman I I kind of tend to agree I
think we're getting to the point where
our information is taken haphazardly all
the time and I think we have to put some
guard rails up and I think this may be a
start to put some of those guard rails
up for people so they can protect their
information so I think we should try to
do something at least to put those guard
rails up and protect the citizens of New
Hampshire anybody else representative
Hill
uh didn't we just pass a constitutional
amendment I just referred to it and
that's why it was in 2018 I believe um
and that's why I took this bill
seriously and have been trying to do
whatever I can to get something adopted
but in spite of that Amendment um and in
spite of RSA 2614 although it does have
some car votes it seems that everybody's
just doing it anyway but but isn't that
the beginning of these guard rails that
Vice chair Gorski
enough anybody else representative C is
there federal regulations that require
the barcode to be on the license can we
prohibit them from putting a barcode on
there or limiting the information that
the barcode has to less than what's on
the actual license
document I will answer that to the best
of my knowledge I don't see anybody from
safety well they do but I they can
correct me if I'm wrong the template we
have right now for our driver's licenses
is federal basically started with the
real ID act uh and even though we did
get um a carve out from the federal
government to allow non-compliant
licenses uh they still look and have the
same template as the real ID so we can
look into it but I don't know if that's
possible represent I think there is a
little bit thank you Mr chairman I think
there is a little bit of a sense of that
the water is already over the dam
especially um where this would only
apply for instate transactions if you've
ever purchased anything online and
they've required a picture of your your
driver's license or any of information
on the front of it they're not bound by
our laws and I don't think there's a
federal law prohibiting that um where I
was wondering I think I agree with M
with representative C is whether we can
limit what information from from the ID
is accessible to different organizations
uh whether if you're buying alcohol that
when they scan your your ID your name
and and age your B date of birth shows
up no other information so there's no
access to that to allow them to store
anything else your white weight anything
like that so
that's I think something that might be
more applicable for us to be able to to
enforce no and thank you it's another
angle getting back to the scanning for
retail the the cigarettes and the beer
and whatever the other thing that I've
noticed since uh I've seen this being
adopted by a lot of Corporations I mean
I won't mention anybody name and give
them give them the notoriety but it
seems like the clerks or the
tellers they're not even looking at the
picture
anymore there is nothing in these these
this bill or this amendment that says
that you they can't ask you for good
cause to inspect your license and when
that happens you're supposed to be
looking at their face and their date of
birth and making sure that this is
actually the person they don't even look
at face anymore they're not even looking
at the license anymore they take it out
of your hand they sometimes they don't
even take it out of your hand they scan
it through the plexiglass so really I
could go in there with my mother's ID
and buy a sixpack and nobody would ever
know the difference how do we even allow
them to have access to that information
through a scanner right well how do how
do they how can they buy a scanner and
have access to that database to begin
with who controls that well again I
don't know uh if you look 255 is an
interesting
read um I I recommend that right after
you get down R say
2614 uh but there are a lot lot of new
definitions on controllers and and and
you know who working for the
corporations gets to set these rules and
what they do with it
um I'm starting to get a sense that we
get this but representative SES did you
have
something well you know I've spent a lot
of time and energy with former state
representative Neil Kirk from where try
exact L um trying to uh protect person's
uh information the cruxs of the matter
from my perspective about this is that I
don't have a problem if people
businesses whomever asks for the
information I don't have a problem with
that the problem I have is storage and
where it gets sent afterwards and I
don't think this bill as we have it or
or even the amendment as we have it
really addresses that more significant
aspect to the problem uh so it's really
hard to support the bill and it's really
hard to support the amendment because it
doesn't fix the real problem the real
problem is what to do what they do with
your information after they see
it what I I understand the
concern I that's my point we don't all
always know um so it's really hard you
know to to to and and for that matter
there's a technical issue too t uh Mr
chairman with your Amendment because
there is no I that I can find 507 DH
colon you know there is no 507 H that I
can find so the the languages in your
amendment is got a problem
anyway that's that's sort of where I'm
at yeah you want to ask me
sure represent Mr chairman if you don't
mind what did you have a that he asked a
question oh no that's where I was going
representative Hill did you have a
question I do
um I understand the storage um concern
that you have do you have a concern as
well of um denying service if you don't
comply with the um with the Turney over
of the license well I think we've had
lots of CA court cases where businesses
are allowed to deny service for a
variety of reasons and I don't see how
we can get in get into that you know
particularly but we as individuals have
a choice to not comply with their
request and they have businesses have
the right to say well we're not going to
do business with you
uh one way or the other there are lots
of businesses who make determinations
that they won't do business
with whatever
whomever but this and not to be
argumentative this doesn't have to be
one of those but um uh well let's look
at the reality of this I'll get a couple
more questions I I I I'm getting the
sense from the committee that we kind of
get the
idea but I also have to be the first to
admit I don't think we're
there we have till the 21st of March to
report out on this that gives us two
weeks
I'll ask a couple more questions who had
your hand represent
pondon thank you Mr chair um I think
your your amendment is on the right path
so I do concur with that uh and I concur
with a lot of the sentiment that has
made thus far especially regarding
storage my concern and I want to make
sure it's clear that this is for
purchasing at retail uh whereas there's
a distinct distinction between
purchasing and leasing at retail Leasing
and I want to then line 11 does state
retail sale of goods and services and by
I want to make sure in legal ease that
covers just the purchasing aspect and
would not affect uh leasing at retail
you mentioned uh Comcast uh some of that
equipment they're over $1,000 a piece so
I can see the justification of getting
some kind of
information uh from a customer because
it's their equipment that's going out
it's the same with retail as well U they
use it anti fraud you know I know
there's a lot of that stuff going on in
our country today and again that's
that's why I've been trying to narrow it
down before we continue I I think we're
looking down the road of an interm study
mistaken no okay that being said it's
unfortunate but there's a lot of moving
parts to this so
so be yet um I know a few of us need to
go to a different thing at noon we've
got some scheduling at 1:00 that we've
got to figure out what to do we've got
the exact session that we could do on
three of them that's that we've already
tackled so far with our recommendations
that should be pretty much
unanimous and I'm going to because of
the sake of time we're going to deal
with uh house
bill
1637 the oldfashioned way we're going to
Duke it out in our executive session so
I'm not going to bring it up in this
work session so anybody else knowing
what was just said need to chime in or
can we go into our lunch break did you
have something represent Jones
no all
right sounds like a plan I'm going to
close the work session and we will be
shooting for one o'clock to get into our
executive
session
all right welcome back everybody
um being 110 I'm going to open up the
executive
session on House Bill 1158 relative to
establishing an exception to vessel
registration sh recognizes
representative Gorski for a motion thank
you Mr chairman I'd like to um make a
motion of uh OTP for HB
1158 motions ought to pass is there a
second second who was that repres
representative Hill uh bill is open to
further Amendment um chair recognizes
representative Gorski thank you Mr chair
d93 okay uh care to speak to your motion
I do thank you
um this this amendment in this this
amendment is to make uh exception to the
uh commercial part of the law and which
will allow a person of U to be 14 years
or older to be able to go off and sell
prepackaged foods and non-alcohol bages
um on a vessel and I think uh this will
promote entrepreneurship in our and our
youth and I think it's a um a great
Amendment uh for us to pursue
thank you sir anybody else from the
committee representative
sites so I would support the motion otpa
um and one of the reasons is
because what was nice about this was
with B bipartisan support we were able
to work through the very many
complicated details that this bill
presented and I think that the work
product is worthy of us
passing thank you sir anybody else from
the
committee seeing none I'll ask the clerk
to call the role on the amendment and
H Vice chairman Gorski
yes representative Smith yes clerk votes
yes representative Hill yes
representative foot yes representative C
yes representative
sers yes representative Coker yes
representative Sykes yes representative
Rich yes representative Fox
yes representative
Rondo I'm sorry it's okay representative
Veo yes representative Jones yes
representative pal mondon yes and
170 okay so the amendment's adopted 170
uh the motion on the floor now is ought
to pass as amended on House Bill 1158
any further discussion from the
committee or can we move on to the
vote being none I'll ask the clerk to
amended Vice chairman Gorski yes
representative Smith yes clerk votes yes
representative Hill yes representative
foot yes representative C yes
representative sers yes representative
Coker yes representative Sykes yes
representative Rich yes representative
Fox yes representative Rambo yes
representative a yes representative
Jones yes and representative pandon yes
and chairman Walsh yes 17 Z
our yep our committee recommendation is
adopted 170 ought to passes amendment I
heard a motion for consent without
objection consent that is I'll close the
1158 um we take up 1457 next just give
do
before I open up the executive session
on House Bill
1457 uh this just uh recently developed
I am going to hold off on the executive
session on House Bill 1637 relative to
reducing requirements for vehicle
inspections I we are looking at some
consensus on actually making some
changes with current law but we're not
there today um so I don't have a date
for a reschedule but I'm not going to be
doing the executive session on that bill
today um that being said are you okay
yeah okay so I'm now I'm going to open
up the executive session on House Bill
1457 FN
establishing penalties for driving over
covered wooden bridges and vehicles that
exceed posted limits and for vehicular
damage to covered wooden bridges chair
recognizes representative foot for a
motion thank you Mr chair I move to
autop pass House Bill 1457 thank you sir
motions ought to pass is there a
second represented by representative
syes care to speak to your motion sir
yes uh essentially this bill
um is introduced as a preventative has
more than a punitive but it what it does
is it it raises the fines for driving
over covered bridge from $62 up to
$1,000 and subsequently $2,000 if
there's a major disruption in traffic
flow or whatnot and it's um basically
prevent Vehicles oversiz driving over
covered
bridges thank you sir anybody else from
the
committee wow maybe we should do work
sessions in advance more up and this is
great uh with no other discussion the
motion is ought to pass on House Bill
1457 I'll ask the clerk to call the roll
when she's
ready Vice chairman Gorski
yes representative Smith yes clerk votes
yes representative Hill yes
representative D yes representative foot
yes representative C yes representative
sers yes representative Coker yes
representative Sykes yes representative
uh Rich yes representative Fox yes
representative Rambo yes representative
a yes representative Jones yes
representative pandon yes and chairman
Walsh yes 18 to Z our recommendation is
adopted 180 of ought to pass on 1457
I'll close the executive
session did I say something wrong oh
session
um why am I drawing a blank here
consent thank you um I just looked at
the fiscal note we should be able to do
that so consent it'll be without
you
okay I'm going to open up the executive
session on House Bill 1273 FN relative
to the protection of personal
information in driver's
motion thank you Mr chairman I move this
is 1273 I move uh interim study for 1273
motion is interim study is there a
second second by representative Jones
can to speak to your
motion yes thank you um I think there's
a lot of good intent behind this bill
and I think there's some pieces that we
all agree on uh just do we have the time
to to work through it and make sure it's
uh ready for prime time as they say um
so I'd like to take a little more time
and uh sincerely work on it over the
can thank you anybody else from the
committee I'll just say a couple of
words um put a tremendous amount of time
into this so
far as I said in our work session I
don't think I can actually duplicate
what I said then
but uh in spite of all the work that's
put in and and thanks to the office of
legislative Service as well uh I find
we're just not there yet if I thought it
was something I could accomplish in the
next two weeks before our deadline I
would not take it up today but I'm being
realistic and stand here defeated so uh
I do also support the interim study and
there's always next year anybody else
from the
committee representative
sers thanks thank you Mr chair I am
going to oppose the inter study
I we can't keep kicking this down the
road this is our private personal
information and it's like we got to deal
with at least something and there's no
reason why we can't at least tell the
retailers stop scanning the licenses and
give them a fine if they do and give
some teeth behind this you know this one
small part of the bill because it's
getting ridiculous out there they're
taking our information we don't even
know what they're doing with them you
know I don't want my my hair color my
height my weight out there and
everything else I mean why should they
even have that and today everything
today is data is King I mean it's like
gold it's like the new gold and it's
like we got to stop this and I think we
should try to push forward in the next
week and a week and a half have
something Rewritten very in clear
English that will stop the retailers
information representative Hill thank
you Mr chairman I don't disagree with
chairman sers and uh and I thought if um
he wanted to take a uh a couple weeks
with a with a subcommittee he um and
then we come back and interim study at
that point I don't know that there's a
harm in that um if he wanted to
try um and put together some kind of
a um simplified version dealing strictly
with retail
operations um it may be something that
the committee would want to entertain
committee representative
s so I I've long been a supporter of
protecting personal information and as I
said earlier during our work session
that it's important for us to recognize
that uh businesses have the right to ask
for this data but in my opinion they
don't have the right to send that data
around somebody else by keeping it um
but it is a complicated thorny issue
deserves us not to rush on it because
when we when we rush legislation then we
make mistakes
unintentionally we make mistakes but
nevertheless we often make mistakes I
don't want to make mistakes with this
because this is a really important issue
important to to our constituents
important to businesses important in so
many different ways and I think we have
shown as a committee that we can work
together in order to try and find
just
applicable reasonable solutions to the
the the questions that present to us in
this body and this issue deserves all of
those
things
anybody
else I find myself in a terrible
situation um usually I work with my
ranking member and try to come to
agreements before these uh we even get
to this point and I did say I would
probably go along with the interim
study only because I have been battling
with this for well over a
month but I have to be honest with you
uh that representative of sellers brings
up a very good point at what
point and we um we are coming back
anyway we actually do have a pretty good
starting point in the amendment that
I've got and you know what with all all
due respect and apologies I'm going to
ask the committee my recommendation to
vote down the interim study so that we
can take this bill up in a few more
weeks anybody else anybody else from the
committee seeing none I'll ask the clerk
study
okay Vice chairman Gorski
no representative Smith
no the clerk votes no representative
Hill no representative D no
representative foot no representative C
no Representative sers no representative
Coker no representative
Sykes yes representative Rich yes
representative
Fox yes representative
Rambo yes representative U yes
representative Jones yes representative
pandon yes and chairman
Walsh
I'm going to recess the public hearing I
mean the executive session on House Bill
1273 I don't have the time specific I'll
be putting it in the calendar scheduled
along with House Bill
you